so I'd say that some the concept of the user story there is one of the key
things that comes out of the engineers offers service cause i think is a key a
software engineering concept and i think it's you know imported i bleep up next
to here in his first so what is a user story the idea and you'll be familiar
with these as they occurred in the in the main MOOC but the idea you know for
it to recap is that they should be short simple people focused our stakeholders
we also call them and business focus so for example as a manager of a consulting
company in order to build my clients accurately I want to track employee time
it's broken up into these this is a very standard sort of thing and why do we
need the user stories partly because you know we need to encourage participation
among stakeholders I see and there's some people who feel the value of these
well I guess it's not so much that I think some people argue with within
things like cucumber which then takes the user stories and breaks them into
these scenarios and there's an argument to say that they're you know the clients
never going to read those but i think the clients are often quite interested
in getting involved at this level at the user story having this you know having
the different kinds of stakeholders involved in writing out these user
stories really i think that the the key thing prep for any project before you
write any to a coat or you even choose your framework or what have you is you
work out what are the needs for the system that you're building and if you
haven't worked that out you haven't got that straight then you know there's just
you know you got your sort of wandering around in the dark really so you know
closely tying the you know the requirements the business needs
absolutely essential and they end up performing the basis for the for the
exception testing as we'll see shortly we talked about some cucumber and our
spec and so on the again i mean i think the particular value that we see for
these i think i think for both centralized or decentralized distributed
teams is having a language description of the hi Louise story
as something so you know what when we work on understanding who it is what
wants what and why it has business values is just absolutely critical for
getting a run on the same page and I think particularly in a you know many
different developers from all the world different backgrounds coming in having
those acceptance tests as well written out based on the user stories and so
that you then have ideally declarative cucumber stories describing you know
what's going on even if you never show those to the customer the you know
between the developers you know who have different levels of experience with you
know whatever low-level coding it's just nice for them to have an English
narrative description so they can all be clear that they're on DM the same page
so you know the risk on extra format as David amala mondo presented in the main
course you know as some stakeholder so that I can you know achieve numbers need
I want to be able to you know do this particular kind of thing on that to
ended up being your kind of feature request that you have there you know
ideal it the the surahs are smart little coverage of that in the textbook with us
you know be them being specific achievable relevant who's got something
we gotta jet they took them in different SMA irrelevant and time boxed so you
know this is I mean this is another sort of neck that comes over time is sort of
working out these these user stories I think we have a particular trouble in
our products with them with time boxing them things often tend to get a bit a
bit open ended but yes definitely do read chapter seven again onto I think I
mean some ways I would almost argue that this is this is sort of the entry point
I mean there's you know in some ways to understand cucumber perhaps you need you
know the grass on the standing of different on the testing and Ruby and so
on but whenever you're sort of starting a new project this is this is the place
where you come in come in with the user stories your own coming with you know
various Ruby code you write come in with some smot some user stories and so
that's you know at the top level that's why we're starting this was going here
so you know what's not at user story you've
got a little technical issues and chores I've attempt to rappers you get a bugs
getting documentation done although you know so plugging kids documented code
that's important and you know features about business needs I mean that this is
you know the key thing you know there's many things that have to be done in
order the project forward and get something else the key thing is that you
you know have to work out which are those small set of things that are going
to really meet business needs and then work out from those the even smaller
stuff that's going to be your MVP or your minimum viable product but so the
the five wise are a technique that I think they've already presented is a
little bit refresher for everyone you know the user story should be able to
reach you know solid business value in five wise so for example about different
user story in order display my products as an online retailer I want to have a
catalog on my website and so we might ask why do you want to include the
catalog on your website and the answer is so we think this customer can see all
the varieties but the products and why should the customer see all the
varieties of the products and if we move down there it's a bit of choice and why
do you want happen to be the choice they're more likely to buy if they they
find what they want and what you want but why you wanted to buy any things I
can make money why do you wanna make money they don't you feel does this
although of course you know that you shouldn't exclude the idea that that is
is money the root of all evil I'm not sure it may be that's you know the tour
the Oerlikon is not specifically you know about commercial goal but being
clear about all the different levels here and also interested assumptions
that are going in here is it the case that necessarily an extraordinarily wide
choice you know it makes people more like to buy in some cases actually
narrowing the choice you know there's something that Sam Evans show that you
know depending upon how you know if you've it's about some people with the
three options they're more likely to choose one than if you put in them 25
options they made us run away in fear like whoa anyhow but the important thing
with any of this whole process of generating user stories and using three
were five cards that are mentioned in the court and so on to uncover the
assumptions about what's needed and why do we think things are the case and you
know whether you I don't know I guess at you know with the team in a single
office or you know in relative good physical proximity
there are more chances meeting of the water cooler to you know or in Maine
meetings to work out what's what's going on it becomes even more important in a
distribute team to understand cover the different assumptions about why you're
developing anything that you think is going to you know have some value to the
end users of your system so simplicity is just I mean is so important up and
down every level from there from the user story to the unit test you know
everywhere you can inject simplicity and complexity that's the way to go so if
you've got sort of a higher more complex feature break that into individual
stories and it'd be very specific and avoid play business needs we've got some
good examples thereof you know example levels been specific you know from from
from David amando that you know the feature you user can search for movies
with a vague but the user can search remove my title is more specific it's a
simple example there so you know there are going to be sometimes just difficult
things that you don't know how to turn into a user story you know every
situation is different just you know break it down into components and keep
asking yourself is this addressing some some key level business need and you
know what are the assumptions that we're making here and I did it should be a
dialogue between you and everybody involved in the product all the
different stakeholders and you know we'll talk more next next week about the
different kinds of you know online framework so you can use to help manage
the development of user stories in the disability team but this yakhni
principle which I of natural I mean you ain't gonna need it I mean this is this
is the key thing that can often happen you get a group of developers together
wouldn't it be cool this really cool and you know lots of things get creative and
the problem is really that complexity is the killer for every additional feature
there's an additional kind of n plus 1 interactions with all of the other
existing features and you know sowed like simplicity simplicity modularity
only building the very very very very smallest subset of the things that you
need really is the way forward so let's use the stories and we'll see them
connecting up with acceptance tests very shortly after
we've had a quick detour into chores alright bye for now